poor Democratic obstruction and
outbursts from left-wing protesters on
Cavanaugh's first full day of
questioning by the Senate Judiciary
Committee Senate Minority Leader Chuck
Schumer trying unsuccessfully to shut
down the hearing earlier the Republican
majority on the Judiciary Committee is
pressing forward with a confirmation
hearing on a Supreme Court nominee whose
record has largely been shielded from
the Senate and the American public the
Republican majority is deliberately
obstructing the Senate's constitutional
duty to fairly and thoroughly conduct
and advise and consent powers President
Trump also weighing in on how his
Supreme Court nominee is handling the
grilling from lawmakers I'm happy with
the capital hearings I watched today for
a little while I saw some incredible
answers to very complex questions he's
an outstanding intellect he's an
outstanding judge he was born for the
position I think that the other side is
grasping at straws and really the other
side should embrace him because you're
never going to find better in terms of
talent or intellect than what you have
in breadth Cavanaugh judge Cavanaugh
easily fending off Democratic attacks he
also laid out his judicial philosophy
and of course answered questions about
Roe versus Wade I'm an independent judge
for 12 years I've been deciding cases
based on the law and the precedent what
sort of loyalty will you owe to the to
the president if confirmed the Supreme
Court and as a sitting judge I owe my
loyalty to the Constitution what would
you say your position today is on a
woman's right to choose as a judge it is
an important precedent of the Supreme
Court by it I mean roe v wade and
Planned Parenthood versus Casey then
reaffirm many times
Casey is precedent on precedent and I
understand the significance of the issue
I always try and I do hear of the
real-world effects of that decision so
Dana do you think that answer about Rove
will satisfy Democrats who are upset
about his nomination well it is the same
answer that Elena Kagan and Sonia
Sotomayor gave in their confirmation
hearings and that was satisfactory to
them so it really isn't about that
answer it's what they believe to be the
underlying political beliefs of that
person so I think I thought he answered
it fine because he answered it just as
the other nominees had done I really
think he was untouchable on substance
today at the beginning when he started
quoting Federalist 69 Hamilton and then
this could go through all of the cases I
mean you really separate the people who
just watch legal dramas on TV versus the
ones who are actually real legal
scholars I always hold back from citing
the federal Jackson on during the
Cinemax
that was an interesting I do think so he
was compelling personally mhm there were
some lighter moments but that was with
the more senior members of the Committee
on the Democratic side even senator
Feinstein at the end of her questioning
said thank you for being so forthcoming
there was a funny moment where he he was
asked what do you want to be remembered
for and he said I want to be remembered
as a good dad and he moved on and
Feinstein whispers and good husband and
there's laughter right so it's like even
if these Democrats don't like President
Trump it's hard for them not to like
Brett Kavanaugh when he's there
answering all of their questions and
interestingly to me I believe that the
Democrats have started to pivot from
trying to block his nomination to trying
to influence him and I would point it
specifically to Senator Whitehouse the
Democrat who said he was concerned about
amicus briefs and who and these outside
groups who are funding them and wasting
the Court's time and that this was bad
and could you do basically it was like
when you get on the bench could you
check into this and Brett Kavanaugh says
I'm actually worried about that too yes
sir I would I'll be happy to and you
mentioned some of the senior members
asking questions some of the junior
senators on the Democratic side are
gonna come up in a little bit senator
Booker perhaps who got felled has a
great imitation I don't know if he's
going to share that but we're gonna dip
into Booker if he comes up in a little
bit yes I will I only do it for special
occasions I have an answer to this
endless marathon because we know let's
face let's face facts we know how this
movie
that's right we know what who's gonna
vote which way and who's gonna vote
against it's kind of like watching die
hard or die hard to you fast through
fast-forward through the slow parts so I
have a solution they should record these
hearings but don't air it live and then
a week later air it but it's we
fast-forward through it so we sit here
and we could boil this down for days
into like 40 minutes to the vote
so everybody so we don't have to so we
already have it like I moved and then we
all just sit that would just fatso okay
this is good then we skip this part
because we're breaking it's it is
interminable and the protesters I think
they're giving protests a bad name yeah
I'm very very Pro protests but not and
not all protesters are crazy but I'm
convinced that all crazy people are
protesters it feels like a mob action of
frustration that they can't somehow you
know have an impact so all these lonely
cranks get together and they scream like
you know like hyenas in a bear trap I'm
sorry I find it objectionable I thought
you're gonna say all crazy people are
Democrats but you would never so I would
never say that because you know what I'm
not into the tribal thing and it
reminded me of something you've said in
the past that the TV cameras and the
networks shouldn't zoom in on the
protesters when they're shrieking like
hyenas
yeah and giving them all the attention
instead like a football game if you have
some streaker run out into the 50 yard
line one NBC and CBS and Fox don't take
it because they don't want to encourage
that type of behavior do you think
that's a good idea
I'm surprised but the problem may be
that I was watching Fox but I didn't see
that they ever focused on a down or the
Protel we don't very much I would say
that the news out of this is one I
wanted to just double down on something
Dana said I think the Democrats
acknowledge the reality it's gonna be
very hard to stop this nominee they
don't have the votes at the same time
what you hear from Republican senator
Graham spokes this today is hey look at
the number of votes that Pryor
candidates got Republican or Democrat
people no Republic
gonna nominate conserves liberals gonna
nominate liberals and he says but I'm so
sorry that you won't be able to say to
your kids your family that you got 90
plus votes in support which is what for
example Scalia got or what I think it
was up in the 60s and maybe seven but
sixties I'm sure that Kagan and
Sotomayor were able to get right so it's
bipartisan but we live in such polarized
times that right now he's just gonna
he's not gonna get any Democratic votes
I don't think I know you guys are
salivating over right get some
Democratic votes
yeah but I'm not sure that they it
matters at this one because I think the
bigger point is a lot oh well it'd be
nice but it doesn't matter in terms of
Graham saying we can get you up so there
it used to be that the Senate would be
sort of you Nana
their unanimous I mean you don't be that
you needed sixty votes but who changed
that are you oh I know who changed that
leader Mitch McConnell's put out by
Republicans Oh Democrats you know
Democrats changed Mitch McConnell said
be careful what you wish for this will
come back to hurt you the Supreme Court
by Reid he's thanking everybody who
encouraged him to do filibuster reform
so that they could do exactly what they
wanted and now today Democrats are
regretting that they ever done well okay
I just disagree because I think that it
was Republicans who did away with the
filibuster on a Supreme Court nominee
[Applause]
sour grapes that you have a different
case but let me just say on the merits
here that I think the important thing
that that is going on is the Democrats
are trying to suggest that look all this
guy's as a rubber stamp he's a political
actor he's been a political actor all
his life and in specific that he's a guy
who would let President Trump off if
Trump is ever tries to self pardon
himself
or request or reject the subpoena from a
prosecutor Katie do you think do you
think he's just a trump rubber Stamper
you think I don't today we learned that
he ruled against the Bush administration
in a very important terrorism case when
he fell against the Bush administration
27 times and what in the one that really
stung was the hummed on too small now I
don't like changing my opinion but on
the lighter side of this as Greg was
saying this has been a long day I would
say that I am happy I got some Harvard
education without the price tag today by
listening to Brett Kavanaugh but I
really liked when he talked about
playing as a team and I think he was
showing his bipartisanship and the idea
that he's going to go into the Supreme
Court it's a team of nine he could be
influenced by the other justices his
work with Elena Kagan the Ted Cruz
exchange when he talked about Merrick
garland and judge Cavanaugh's work with
Merrick garland how they agreed on 90s
he said be influenced by Elena Kagan
you're changing your mind my point is
that Democrats are seeing this now and
Republicans actually helped portray this
that he's not this right-wing crazy guy
he's actually a pretty moderate
middle-of-the-road conservative
[Laughter]
right-wing Trump well how would you say
it my poet laureate friend you want
someone who is Trumpy and is gonna be
another can I just say one last thing
that we've learned about a lot about the
founding of the country in Federalist
seventeen and all this today but I by
some consent is what the Senate is
supposed to do and it was you purely
about for a long time about
qualifications he is highly qualified
everyone agrees with that yeah but it's
not about qualifications it's like the
swing Standards Board is looking right
now